we know that if we have some linear
transformation that's a transformation
from x to y and these are just sets the
sets of vectors and t is a linear
transformation from y to z that we can
construct a composition of s
with t that is a linear transformation
from x all the way to z
we saw this several videos ago and the
definition of our linear transformation
or the composition of our linear
transformation so s the composition of s
with t
applied to some vector x
in our set x our domain is equal to
is equal to s
of
t of x
this was our definition and then we went
on and we said look if s of x
if s of x can be represented as the
matrix multiplication
a x
the matrix vector product and if t of x
can be represented or the transformation
t can be represented as the product of
the matrix b with x
we saw that this thing right here
which is of course if we just write it
this way this is equal to
a
times t times x which is just bx
we saw in multiple videos now that this
is equivalent to by our definition of
matrix
products this is equal to the matrix a b
right when you take the product of two
matrices you just get another matrix the
product a b
times x so you take essentially the
first linear transformation in your
composition its matrix which was a and
then you take the product with the
second one fair enough all of this is
review so far so let's take three linear
transformations
let's say that i have the linear
transformation h
and when i apply that to a vector x it's
equivalent to multiplying my vector x by
the matrix a
let's say i have the linear
transformation
g
when i apply that to a vector x it's
equivalent to
multiplying that matrix time that
that vector there should be a new
concept called a vectrex it's equivalent
to multiplying that vector times the
matrix b and then i have a final linear
transformation
f
applied when it's applied to some vector
x it's equivalent to multiplying that
vector x times the matrix
the matrix c
now what i'm curious about is what
happens when i take the composition of h
with g i take the composition of h with
g and then i take the composition of
that with f
and then i take the composition of that
with f these are all linear
transformations and then i apply that to
some vector x
and then i apply that
to some
vector x which is necessarily going to
be in the domain of this guy i haven't
actually drawn out their domain and
co-domain definitions but i think you
get the idea so let's explore what this
is a little bit well by the definition
of what a let's go back by this
definition right here of what
composition even means we can just apply
that
to this right here so
we can just imagine this as being our s
if we imagine this was our s and then
this is our
t right there then what is this going to
be equal to if we just do a straight up
pattern match right there this is going
to be equal to
s the transformation s applied to the
transformation f applied to x so s is h
of g
so it is
h
or i shouldn't say h of g the
composition of h with g
the composition of h with g that is our
s
and then i apply that
i apply that
to
f applied to x f is rt i apply that to f
applied to x
just like that
now what is this equal to what is this
equal to
now we can imagine that this is our this
is our x if we just pattern match
according to this definition that this
is this guy right here that this is our
t
and that this is our s
and that this is our s and so if we just
pattern match here this is equal to what
this is just straight from the
definition of a composition
so it's equal to s of s is our h
so h of
t which in this case is g
g
applied to x but instead of an x we have
a whole this this vector here which was
the transformation f applied to x
so g
of f of x
that's what this equal to the
composition of h with g
and the comp or the composition of f
with
h the composition of h and g
all of that applied to x is equal to h
of g of f of x now what is this equal to
what is this equal to well this is equal
to i'll do it right here
this is equal to
h
the transformation h applied to what is
this term right here i'll do it in pink
what is this
that is the composition of g and f
applied to x you can just replace s with
g and f with t and you'll get that right
there so this is just equal to the
composition of g
with f
applied to x
that's all that is
now
what is this equal to
right there and it's probably confusing
to see two parentheses in different
colors but you get the idea what is this
equal to
well just go back to your definition of
the composition
i just want to make it very clear what
we're doing this is if you imagine this
being your
t and then this being your s this is
just the composition of s with t applied
to x
so this is just equal to
all right like this way this is equal to
i shouldn't write s's this is the
composition of h
with
the composition of g
and f and then all of that applied to x
now why did i do all of this well one to
show you that the composition is
associative i went all the way here and
then i went all the way back and
essentially it doesn't matter where you
put the parentheses the composition of
the composition of h with g with f is
equivalent to the composition of h with
the composition of g and f that these
two things are equivalent and
essentially you can just these two
things you can just rewrite them
the parentheses are
essentially unnecessary you can write
this as the composition of h with g
with f
all of that
applied to x
now
i took the time to say that i can
represent h as a matrix that each of
these linear transformations i can
represent as matrix multiplications why
did i do that well we saw before that
any composition when you take the
composition of s with t
the matrix version of this
transformation of this composition is
going to be equal to the product by our
definition of matrix matrix products the
product of the trans the esses
transformation matrix and t's
transformation matrix so what are these
going to be equal to
so this one right here if you think of
this transformation right here this
statement right here it's it's matrix
version of it so let me write that the
matrix version of
the composition of h
with g
apply and then the composition of that
with f
applied to
x
applied to x
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to and we've seen
this before first the first tr the the
product of these matrices so this
composition its matrix is going to be a
b
h and g their matrices are a and b so
it's going to be a b
a
b and i'll do it in parentheses and then
you take that matrix and you take the
product because so this guy's matrix
representation is a b right and this
guy's matrix representation is c so the
matrix representation of this whole
thing is this guy taking the product of
a b and then taking the product of that
with c
so a b
and then c
and then if you look at this guy right
here
and of course all of that times a vector
x all of that times some
vector x right there that's the vector x
now let's look at this one right here
if we take the composition
the composition of h
with
the composition of g and f and apply all
of that to some
vector x what is that equivalent to
well this composition right here the
matrix version of it i guess we can say
is going to be the product bc and we're
going to apply that to x
so we're going to have the product bc
and then we're going to take the product
of that with this guy's matrix
representation which is a
and we've shown this before we never
showed it with three but it extends just
i mean you know i kind of showed it
extends you can just keep applying the
definition you can keep applying this
property right here and so it'll just
naturally extend because every time
we're just taking the composition of two
things even though it looks like we're
taking the composition of three we're
taking the composition of two things
first here and then we get its matrix
representation and then we take the
composition of that with this other
thing so the matrix representation of
the entire composition is going to be
this matrix times this matrix which i
did here similarly here we take first
the matrix
the the composition of these two linear
transformations and their matrix
representation will be that right there
and then we take the linear we take the
composition of that with that so it's
the entire matrix representation is
going to be this guy's matrix times this
guy's matrix so a times bc and of course
all of that applied to the vector x
now in this video i've showed you that
these two things are equivalent if
anything the two the parentheses are
completely unnecessary and i showed you
that there they both essentially come
boil down to h of g of f of x so these
two things are equivalent so we could
say essentially that these two things
over here are equivalent
or that
a
b the product a b and then taking the
product of that matrix with the matrix c
is equivalent to taking the product a
with the matrix
b c which is just a product another
product matrix or another way of saying
is that these parentheses don't matter
that all of these is just equal to a
b c
or this i mean this is just a statement
that matrix products exhibit the
associative property
associative
property it doesn't matter where you put
the parentheses and you know sometimes
it's confusing in the word associative
it just means you don't doesn't matter
where you put the parentheses matrix
products do not exhibit the commutative
property we saw that in the last video
we cannot in general
we cannot make the statement that a
b
is equal to
ba we cannot do that and in fact in the
last video i think it was the last video
i showed you that this if a b is defined
sometimes ba is not even defined or b a
is defined sometimes a b isn't defined
so it's not commutative it is
associative though in the next video
i'll see if matrix products are actually
distributive